よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは この 本当のことを知りたいという人間の希望についてなんです
しかし 副題は人は現実から
これ逃避というんですか
逃げてしまう  そちらに何かあの
なんか矛盾が成り立っていますね
本当のことを知りたいと
と誰でも思っている しかし
みんな現実から逃げてしまう
現実に背を向く そこがそのポイントなんですね
それで最初にこの質問に答えて話が始まります
人はどうしてやたらと知りたがるのでしょうか
もうやたらと知りたがりますよ
これはね まあおそらく人間だけの問題だと思います
これもあれこれと知りたがるのは
まあ人間のことしか私たちあまり知りませんしね
なんでしょうかね そんなにも知りたがるの
我々一人一人も同じことでしょうしね
もうやたらと知りたがるんですよ
あれどういう病気ですかね
で それ一つ答えはないと思います
なぜ知りたがるんでしょうかという一つの答えはないと思いますが
分析して考えてみると
なんとか答えが出るとは思います
何を知りたがりますかと
そのケースバイケースで理由わかるんですよ
例えば料理作っている人が新しいレシピを知りたがるでしょう
当たり前で 新しい料理方法なんかないんですかと
それでいろいろ調べるんですね
で いくら調べていても
これで十分だと 知り尽くしたと
料理について で これからは知る必要はないんだぞということは成り立たないんですね
それで料理作る人は新しいレシピを
なんで自分もうとっくに知ってるのに
もうとっくに料理を作ったりしているのに
なぜ新しいものにチャレンジしたり
調べたりするんですかね
それは一つの小さなケースで考えると
具体的に考えると この原因見えてくると思いますね
何でしょうかね それで頭の中はただ料理作っている人のイメージだけ置いておいてください
そうするとわかりやすいと思います
やっぱりその料理作っている人が
自分 今まで持っている能力に知識に満足していないんですよ
もっと知った方がもっといいんじゃないかなと
だからはっきりと言えば
自分の能力について 自分の知識について納得いってない
不満を持っている その不満を持ってるんだから
まあ知りたがるんです
これで足りるわけじゃないんだと
これぐらいの知識で 私には私に右に立つ人はいませんよと
世の中に言えないんだと
で それはどんなケースで考えたっても同じことなんですよ
料理作っている人が新しいレシピを探したりする
デザイナーが新しい新しいいろんなデザイン
いろんな方面で考えたりする
調べたり探したりする
ですから ケース一つ 具体的なケース一つを見てみると
料理作っている人がやっぱり自分の能力に知識に不満を持っている
これでは足りませんと
このこれで足りませんという気持ちがずっといろんなものを知りたがるという衝動を起こしてしまいますね
で いろんなものを探していく
では その人は完全な 例えば料理について完全たる知識得るんでしょうかね
得られないんですよ 寿命は寿命は足りません
世の中にあらゆる料理方法を勉強しなくちゃ我慢でき
納得いかないし そんな寿命っていうのは人間にあるわけじゃないんですよ
しかし 料理っていうのはいろいろ組み合わせだからね
知ってるものの組み合わせも限りなく出てくるんですよ
知ってる料理 知ってる人にとっては
あまり料理 料理を知らない人は一つ二つしか思い浮かべないんですけどね
まあ例えば野菜の料理の場合は
まあ茹でるか天ぷらにするか
それしか頭に浮かばない人もいますけど
で まだ他の方法もあるかもしれません
だから料理そんなにできない人には一つ二つしか思い浮かばないんですが
知ってる人にとってはもう無数にこういうこともできる
こういうこともできるんじゃないか
こういうこともできるんじゃないかと無数に出てくるんですよ
ですから 自分知ってる料理の中でも無数に組み合わせが出てきて
さらに新しいデータが入れちゃうと
さらにさらに無数にものが出てきて
そんなのは試してみて美味しいかないかとかね
人の寿命は足りなくなっちゃうんですよ
ですから 死ぬ時も私たちはもっと知りたかったのにという気持ちで死ぬだろうとは思います
それからね やっぱりみんな
負けたくない 一人前になりたいという気持ちもあります
自分知ってる世界でプロになりたいと
一番目になりたいと その気持ちもまた無限に我々をもう働かせてしまうんですね
だから 料理の人の例に戻ると
料理の人はもう一人前になりたい
一番目になりたい 日本一になりたい
いや 世界一になりたいというふうに気持ちが出てくるんですよ
それで調べなくちゃいけないんですね
知っておかないといけないんですね
一番目になりたい 世界一になりたいっていう希望って何でしょうかね
それが高慢でしょ   自分を大きく見せたいんですよ
だからやたらに知りたがる人っていうのは
もうかなり高慢という病気もあるんです
で 高慢というのは自分が偉いという考え方で
自分が偉いと思わなくてもいいでしょ
なんでそんな偉いと夢見ているんですかね
心の中虚しいんですよ
それ空っぽなんです 充実してないんです
悲しいんです 苦しいんです
無意味です 心の中は 本当は何の喜びも感じない
無意味な無意味という感覚で
苦しいという感覚で で
この高慢に英語でヴァニティという言葉があるんですよ
威張るという意味で ヴァニティという言葉は
ヴェインという言葉から作っている
空っていう膨らましていると
風船みたいに だから威張りたくなる
自分をちょっと大きく見せたい
社会の中で自分が一人前
もう何か腕に何か技を持っている
何かできる それでみんなにちやほやされたいという
気持ちがその高慢から出てくるんですよ
それで実際に世の中でね
世界一っていうふうに言える人々はいますよ
そういう人々は生まれつきその才能があって
いつも簡単に まあ進んで進んでいて
自分の世界で 自分の分野で世界一になってしまうんですね
その時も その人々には
まあ私は世界一ではないかと
ちょっとその考え方入ってしまうんですね
それはどうしようもないんですよ
みるみる人は自分よりは能力がないんですね
そうすると 自分ってすごい偉いんじゃないかなというふうに
新しく高慢が入ってきます
その時点から その人はどんどんどんどん減っていくんですよ
それで一流のプロでも
世界一のプロでも壁にぶつかるんですよ
能力がなくなってしまうんです
昨日  NHK で同じ話を聞いたんですけど
なんかあの 音楽家 ジャズピアニストのマコと
なんです 誰でしたっけ？川田かこうだかなんとかで
世界一流の まあ ２歳でも音楽のことをすごくわかっていたという
なんか幼稚園か小学生で
なんか先生がピアノを弾いてると
先生それ間違ってるよと
いきなり怒鳴っても 先生がいえ
間違ってないんだよ ちゃんと楽譜でちゃんとそのようにあるんですよと言って
まあそれはまあ子供だからなんとかならない
それで先生はもう何か調べたところで
まあ本にはちゃんとあるようにピアノを弾いたんですけど
あと調べたら この本作ったところで間違ってたんだと
だから誰にも気がつかないことは
この子は何のことなく発見だと
それは能力あること確かにありますけど
それでその人も言ったのは
まあすごい自分が威張っていたんだと
ある時点までは それで自分はもう散々馬鹿にしちゃったのは自分に結婚している奥様だと
あんたの音楽なんか聞いても気持ち悪くてたまらんと
それだと世界一の人にとってはすごくもう爆発するんだから
光がね そういうふうにいろいろ言われて
まあどんどんどんどんやっぱり自分が鎧を被っていたんだと
それはもう捨てなくちゃいけないというふうに
自分の人格をものすごいもう直すために協力してくれたという話で
やっぱりそのそれ見たら
この同じことだと その人々は世界一になっているのは
別に 何のこともなく まあただできるんだからなんですよ
生まれた瞬間から 赤ちゃんの時から
もうそういう音にすぎて
えらい敏感でもうわかってしまっているということで
それでささっとするするともう一流になってしまう
アメリカのバークレー大学で
音楽大学はもう最優秀で卒業して
それからもうカーネギーホールで演奏
すごい経歴 経歴なんですが
とにかくそれで淡々と進んで進むんですが
それ我々と違って そういう人々には高慢のあれ鎧がじわじわと入ってくるんですよ
それ破らないと また能力も何もなくなってしまうんですね
でも世界みんな天才じゃないんだから
我々はそなた多勢だからね
我々は知りたがる時は初めからもうこの高慢の鎧を被っているんですよ
威張ってやろうではないかと
みんなに見せてやろうではないかと
だから知りたがるんでしょう
だから我々は知識得るためにえらい苦労してるんですよ
勉強してもしても忘れてしまうし
勉強すればするほど頭がどんどん悪くなってしまって
どうなっているか自分でもわからなく状態になってしまうんですね
天才的な人にとってはそれはないんですよ
まあなんだこれっていう感じで
さーっと最後まで行ってしまいますけど
それで振り返ってみると
もうみんな遠く遠く自分だけ走っているんですね
それでみんな足がもう鈍いじゃないかと
じゃあ私と一緒に誰にも走れないんだというふうに
後からもうこれが入ってくるんですよ
ですから 天才の人でも何も能力なくなっちゃって
壁にぶつかって不幸になるということはもうかなりあります
そこら中にあります 天才と言われる人々の人生
なんかちょっと調べてみてください
もう結構かなりやたらにあります
それが後からこの高慢という病気が出てくる
だから世界の人々もそういう人々に対して何も言わないんですよ
あまりにも怖くて あまりにも才能がありすぎて
みんな神様扱いしてしまう
ですから そういう人々に自分を見直すために
機会もないんですよ 残念なことに
我々一般の人々の場合は
もう知識得るのも大変苦しくて
もう頑張って頑張って
勉強してもしてもうまくいかないし
それでそこら辺で手を打ってもう威張り始まるんですよ
そうすると社会に行ったらすぐ馬鹿にされちゃいますね
相手にされないとか それで自分を見直す機会があるんですよ
しかし 見直せません 落ち込むんです
認めてないんだと  そういうふうなことなんですが
ですからこの心の問題なんですね
どう見ても なぜそんなにやたらに知りたがるんでしょうかといえば
やっぱり自分に対しては
自分を知っているものに対しては不満を持っている
だから いくら知っても知っても
知りきれない 世の中の情報っていうのは
死ぬ瞬間まで不満で死ぬことになる
それ一つ それで自分の立場を作ろうと
私は何々者ですよと世間に言いたがるところが
それは高慢で それが心の中
ものすごい空っぽだから
無意味で充実感がなくて
生きることは苦しくて
もうどうにもならない
それ 何とかしようということで
ちょっとしたかぶりをかぶるんですよ
知識という そういうことで
まあもともと高慢で始まる仕事だから
もうプロになれるのは本能が損ない人々で
プロになっても まあ苦しさっていうのはもう自分もできた世界で
苦しさっていうのは ただ人生苦しいっていうのは置いておきましょう
自分のプロの世界での苦しさ
野球選手が野球で得る苦しみ
あれは何でしょうかと
自分がもう能力ついてるのに
その仕事をするときもかなり苦しんだりする
ですから 結局 自然に普段人生っていうのは大変苦しいもので
その上何とかしようとプロ的な知識を持って生活はするんだけど
その仕事の世界でも並ならぬ苦しみを感じることになってしまうんですね
だから 音楽の場合でも
アマチュアの人が楽しく演奏しているのに
プロの人はそうじゃないんですよ
えらい苦しい ということになってしまうんです
そういうふうに この知りたがるのは何なのかと
仏教的に調べてみると
そんなふうな答えが出てきます
もし広がったら後で言ってみてください
はい  それからもう一つ
この世の中で やっぱり何か身についてないと生活できないんで
それはすごい具体的な話で
何か勉強していないと仕事はない
仕事がないともう食べていられない
この世の中で まあ一応生きることっていうのは大変苦しくなりますね
そこら辺はまあすごい具体的な話で
まあなんとかまあ仕事を探さなくちゃいけない
それには何か何か能力がないと
今頃そんな仕事はあるわけじゃないんだと
そういうことで では勉強してみましょうと
その場合は自分が何か仕事をして
それでお金を設けて 楽に生きていきたいという気持ちなんですね
それがやっぱり人間には
まあやめなさいということは言えないんですよ
なぜならば 人は誰でも何かを仕事をしてご飯を食べなくちゃいけないということは
人間にとってはもうこれはもう
絶対的な条件で 人間で生まれたならば
仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
まあ動物はまあ仕事を何かなくても餌を探すことができますが
やっぱりそれでもその中で餌の探し方っていうのはあるんですね
まあそれはほとんど生まれつきついているものもあるし
まあ狩りのやり方やらね
それはまあなんとか簡単に親教えてあげるし
まあそれで学校なくても済みますよ
動物の世界では でも人間の世界ではやっぱり学校がないと仕事は成り立たなくなっているんですね
だからそれはあの そう簡単には否定できません
何も知りたがるなよということは
まあそう簡単には言えません
で  そこは仏教の言葉から言えば
やっぱり生きたい生きたいと死にたくないという渇愛欲
それは誰でも死にたくはないんだから
まあ誰でも生きてるんだったら楽に生きたい
生きていきたいと思ってるんだからね
それだったらそれなりの技を身につけなさいということになってしまうんですね
だから勉強 何か勉強するか習うかということは
必然的に人間がやらなくてはいけないことなんですね
だから勉強嫌いだということも
またかえってすごい病気なんです
だから勉強嫌いだというと
そんなこと言わないで学校に行きなさいではなくて
何か精神的な思考パターンがどこか狂ってるんです
そこら辺直してあげないと
でもそれはほとんどしないでしょうね
世の中で 勉強はしたくないという人を見て
勉強できないという人を見て
どちらにしたっても この思考パターンの中でちょっとした問題があります
その精神的な問題を直してあげないとうまくいかない
なぜならば 何か勉強するということは
...必要なんです 皆様が考えているこの単なるこの塾に行って
もう全てもう丸ごと丸暗記して全部吐き出すという試験で
そんなのは勉強ではありませんが
勉強っていうのはただ生きるために必要なものですからね
ですから 一度も学校に行かなくても
文字書けなくても ちゃんと何か身につくことはできますよ
何か職業を身につくことはできます
で それでその人はその職業で一生食べていられますよ
ですから 必ずしも全ての人々は学校に行って大学卒業しなくちゃいけないということが全く非論理的ないい加減な言葉なんです
だから なんで我々は知らなくてはいけないかというと
仕事をしてご飯を食べるためなんです
その場合は 仏教だったらはっきりする
自分がどういう仕事をしてしたいか
どういう仕事で自分には楽に収入を得られるかと思って
それだけ知っておけば十分ですが
それで終わらないんですよ
それでそれだけで職業に制限して
ちゃんと気楽に安定して収入を得るようなことを考えて
何か勉強するか 何か習ってみる
それだったら一生勉強しなくちゃいけないという
あの苦しみが消えるはずなんです
私の仕事の場合は これぐらいのことを知っておけば十分だよという
この境界線見えるんですよ
だから幸せな人っていうのは
やたらに知りたがるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと境界線をつけておくんですよ
ここまでやと それ以上あっても関係ないんだと
そういう風に境界線を置いておくことができれば
かなりいいんじゃないかなと思います
いわゆるこの世の中で
どこまで知ったってもまだ足らないんだからね
前の例にまた戻してみますけど
料理の専門家がもっと知りたい
もっと知りたいということで調べると
死ぬまでまだ残っているんですよ
だから納得いかないんですよ
自分がもう本当に一流になりましたかと
世界一になったかというところで納得いかないで死んでしまうんですよ
だから たとえ職業のためであろうとも
そのその人にとっては
やっぱりどこかで境界線をちゃんと決めておかないと
生きることが苦しみになってしまうんですね
すべて逆に回転するんですよ
だから知って知ってはいく
そうすると みんなより私は知ってるんだぞという高慢が出てくる
そうするとさらに苦しみが増える
そうすると能力が全部なくなってしまう
途中でやめる人もいますよ
一生勉強研究してきた専門分野なのに
いきなりやめてしまうと
私は画家のことを聞いたことはありますけど
ものすごい素晴らしい能力があって
ある時点でもうやめたと
筆をおろしたと もう二度と一生触りませんということで
死ぬまで筆を触ったことはない
それから それはどういうことかで
その人は最後に作った作品というのはかなり大げたなもので
大変力をそれに絞っただろうと思います
それで次のことっていうのは
それより立派なものでないと
でもこれ以上どうすればいいかと
それで同じことを繰り返しちゃうととんでもないことになっちゃうんですね
あの先もこれは全く同じではないかと
そうすると自分のプライド
帰属 また描くんだったら
あれより何かびっくりするものを描かなくちゃいけないし
でももうできん すべて力をあれに絞ったし
それでまあやめるしかないということで
これっきり描かないということにしたんですけどね
そういうことで このいろんな我々は勉強して
知り 知り 知って知っていくんだけど
時々そういうことも起こるんですよ
だからせっかくやめてしまえばいますね
時々若いうちにやめてしまう
もう何かずっと勉強していて
まあどこかでまあ 25
6年前にやめました 全部やめたと
言っちゃうと 今までの動力は全部ね
もう何の役にも立たなくなっちゃいますよ
だから境界線を引いて勉強するのはどうせ当たり前
確実にやらなくちゃいけないことをし
自分の生き方ね それで食べていられる
これではいくらか社会で生きていられる
みんな私をそれなりに批判したっても
完全に無視することはできないんだ
私は何かできるんだよというところで
いくらかそこまでやらないと
英語を勉強するんだったら
まあ最低手紙書けるぐらいはね
手紙一通書けるぐらいのところまででも頑張ってもらわないと
小説やらそういう本とかね
まあ本ぐらいは読める
もう喋らなくてもね まあ喋るということは別な能力でしょうし
まあ喋らなくてもよろしいんですから
まあいくらか書いてあげるぐらいでもね
まあ勉強した方がいいんですよ
ただ もう何にも役に立たないですが
えらい苦労すると 英語の勉強にはね
そういうはもう時間の無駄でエネルギーの無駄になっちゃうんですね
それは知りたがるということでの話で
もう一つありますね やっぱり知らなきゃまだ不安でしょう
生きていられないし 人に騙されやすいし
自立できませんね 何も知らない場合は
そういうことで 自立するために
独立するために やっぱり知る
知っておかなくてはいけないということになります
しかし 何を知るかということはちゃんと判断しておかないと
何でも知りますよということはあまりいいことではありません
それで 世の中で何でも知る人もいますよ
あれもこれも何にでも頭を出してみる
その人々はまあ誰一人も一人前にはなりません
何でもちょっと舐めただけで役に立たないんですよ
だからいろんな人がたくさんいろんな分野のことを知っているような人々はいます
いるんだけど 結局は仕事になるし
ものって何かというと
どちらも中途半端で もう仕事として頼めないんですよ
頼んでみたら中途半端で役に立ちません
音楽もいろいろやってますよと
もう作文 それいろいろ書いてますよと
料理もいろいろやってますよ
と何でもいろいろやってますよと
あれも知ってる これも知ってると
ではこれを頼みますと言ったところでできない
頼む場合はそれなりのプロでないと
できないんだからね ですから
何も勉強していない人と同じことになってしまいますね
ただ 私は何でも知ってるぞというとんでもない病気だけで病気だけがかかって
そういうことで知りたがるのは悪く
悪くないではなくて それは避けられない
仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
それだけ覚えておいてください
そんなに知るということで
我々はそんな大したことになるわけじゃないんですよ
だから学校に行くのも
大学に行くのも いろんな研究するのも
何か職業のためではないかと
そういうことで そこら辺で境界線をつけておけば
楽しく生きていられます
そこでこの 本当のことを知りたいというテーマに入ってみると
なんかすごいなんか誤解が起きてくるんではないかなと
みんな狂暴で他人に攻撃しているんですね
本当のことを教えてくれと
結局 この本当のことを知りたいということで
世の中でも戦いしかないんですね
我々は他人を攻撃しますよ
本当のことを言ってくれと
そう攻撃するとどうなるかというと
向こう側はもう徹底的に隠す
それでどこまででも戦っていくんですよ
いろんな政治的に考えてみて
いろんな国を責めてみてください
本当のことを教えてくださいと
本当のことを教えてくださいと攻撃すればするほど
向こう側も徹底的にもう門を閉ざす
情報が漏れないようにする
漏れないようにして あまりにも攻撃すると
それなりの適切にもう組み合わせた創作した情報を与えるんですよ
それで知ったそうと こちらは威張っちゃいますけど
まるっきり作った話で嘘なんですね
だから本当のことを教えてくれというふうに我々は切望していますが
それ自体が事実を隠すんですよ
で 北朝鮮と日本はあまり関係はなかった
まだまだ作ってないんですけど
これから関係 協力関係を作ろうとしている時点ですからね
その時点 その出来事が起こる以前は
日本人みんな韓国っていうのはすごい敵国として見て
本当のことを教えてくれと誘拐したんではない
拉致したんではない 日本
しかし あまりにも攻撃すると日本政府も知らんぷりをする
向こうは徹底的に否定する
逆に向こうの放送では
こうやってもう日本は我々偉大なる北朝鮮民をもう侮辱しようとしているんだと
そんなにはもう負ける
負ける 負けるんですかと
そういう根拠のない 国を馬鹿にするために言う
こういう話 そういうふうに向こうの放送をして
一般国民にそれを言う
こちらにも凶暴な態度をとる
はっきり言うと 全然どうなっているかとわからない
証拠はないということになってしまうんですね
だから事実知りたい場合は
攻撃態勢で行くと事実ではなくて
全く違う作ったものをしか知ることできないんですね
知ること 違った変わったことを知ることになるんですね
それで北朝鮮と日本がいくらかんでも仲良くしてみようではないかと
仲良くするためには ちょっとちょっと
なんで我々仲良くしなかったという
これちょっと原因がありますから
そこら辺で仲良く だから仲良くしようというテーマが出たところで
向こうは先にこれ こういうこういう人が拉致しましたよと先に発表するんですね
それで国が発表したことは
まあそれは認めざるを得ないし
だから私はすごい大した問題と思いますよ
国が認めるということが
これ大変なことなんです
でも その事実を知ることができたのは
ずっと闘ってきたんだからではありませんね
もしすごいこちらでもう反感を徹底的に持って
手を挙げて もうなんとかもうデモでもやっている状態だったら
さらに悪い結果になるだけで
事実は出てこない 世の中はそうやって相手を敵に回して
本当のことを知りたい
教えてくれとスパイを送ったりとかね
で 送れば送るほど向こうも事実を隠す
だからそこら辺もまず仏教的に理解してほしいんですよ
我々は本当のことを知りたいと言ったっていうのは
結局相手に対して侮辱やら攻撃やらしているんだから
相手も隠すんですよ それ不思議な法則なんですよ
だから お母さんが自分の子供のことを知りたくて
子供がいない時 部屋に入って引き出しの中やら片っ端から調べるとどうなるんですかね
それっきり その子供は何をやっているかさっぱりわからなくなるんです
全くも言わなくなるんです
母親を信頼しなくなるんです
それでやることは全部家でではなく
外でやっちゃうんですね
それでとんでもない結果でしょ
母親に対しては全くも犯罪を起こす
とんでもない子供を作ったことになってしまっちゃうんです
だから本当のことを知りたいというふうに行動するっていうことは
結果としては全くも知らないで
全くも逆の結果で終わってしまうんですよ
誰でもそれ好きじゃないんですよ
自分のことをいちいちいち調べるんだったら
あるいはこれを調べる人の人格自体がものすごい汚くてできてないんですよ
それすっごい醜い性格なんです
だから自分がすごい醜い人間で
醜い性格の人間で子育てをしちゃうと
当然の結果 ものすごい社会から見ても
もう何百倍も醜い人間を作ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 本当のところは本当のことを知りたいということは
ものすごい不幸を作って
逆結果を出してくれる人間の行動なんです
だから本当のことって何ですかね
例えば自分の子供だから
もうまだまだ未成年だから全部知っておかなくちゃいけないんだそうと
と思うことっていうのは
自分の欲望であって 人を支配しようとすることであって
しかし どんな人でも支配されたくはない
自分だけの世界っていうのはみんな持っている
それにはいろんな人が勝手に入り込んだり
侵入したりするのはすごく嫌がるんです
だから 相手に対しては知っているんだぞという気持ちをなくすことが本当のことなんです
相手のことは知ってないんだと
これも  NHK テレビで見たちょっとした出来事なんですけど
おじいさんとおばあさんが NHK じゃない
まあ覚えてない チャンネルは
覚えるまではずっと見ていない
ちょっと 1 分 2 分でまあ他のことをするんだから
私も で ちらっと目に入るだけで
それでまあ おじいさんとおばあさんがもう何か文句言ってるんですけど
このおばさんが この人は全く私のことは理解してくれないんだと
それはおじいさん そんなの当たり前でしょう
わかるわけないでしょうと
長い間一緒に生活していて
そんなの当たり前でわかるわけないです
でも女性の方がそれを納得いかないんですよ
でも男性が言ったことは正しいんですよ
奥さんのことを知ろうとしなかったんだから
長い間一緒にいたんです
それで人っていうのはアホバカっていうことはそういうところでなんですよ
だから自分が気楽に楽しくずっと生きていたのは
男の方がいちいちいちいちあれ調べよ
これをこれしろ これは何ですか？あれは何ですか？とかね
なんでそういうことをするんでしょうかとかね
そういうことを全くしなかったからなんですよね
しかし 自分のことをよく理解してほしいと理解しちゃったら
その即すぐ利己になるんだからね
だからその矛盾をなくしてみると
またかなり楽なんですよ
女性たちっていうのはもう真っ赤な嘘を言ってるんですよ
私の気持ちを分かってくれないとかね
だから自分が真っ赤な嘘を言ってる
ことは理解しておくと
また楽なんですよ 文句言う人生がなくなるんですよ
結婚してずっと死ぬまで旦那に文句を言う
で 文句を言うたびに自分が不平不満で生きていることになるんだからね
この男に尽くしているのに
全然私の気持ち 私のことを理解しようとしないんだぞとかね
だから理解しようとしないんだからこそ
平和で夫婦仲良く生きていられるんですよ
それで女性たちっていうのは
もうただもう秘密の塊で
これ あまりにも自分だけの世界に閉じ込まれているんだから
この噂話する場合は女性の方が強いんですね
ずっと人の噂話 あれやこれやと言い張ったりしていて
まあ男も暇があったらやるでしょうとは思いますけど
わからないんですけどね
今の時点で考えちゃうと
男で暇があったらふざけて遊ぶだけで
酒なんか飲んで まあそれで終わっちゃいますし
若者だったら喧嘩したりなんとかして
もう大したことはやってないんですよ
で 女性に暇があると 誰かの噂を
それでまた仲良くしているんだと
女同士で という またそれまたとんでもない嘘なんですよ
全然仲が良くないんですよ
だからそういう風に表面上の生き方っていうのを
かなり苦しむんですね
だから正直になっちゃえば簡単ですよ
私のことなんかあんたにわかるわけないんだよと
だから一生至っても互いに理解しないということが事実
本当 それが本当のことなんですよ
それ言うとそれに逆らっちゃうんですね
私が仏教を喋ろうと思って
なんかただ余計なことを言っているのではないかと
でもそれが残念な残念ながらそれが仏教なんです
本当のことを言っちゃうという
私たちは思っている 本当のことと違いますね
あまり複雑に考えないで
あ そうですかと この世の中で結婚している夫婦というカップルと地球上ずっと調べてみても
互いに理解していないんですよ
なんでそれだったら決めないんですかね
やっぱり夫婦っていうのは互いに理解しないもんだよと
それ決めないで踏ん張るんですね
夫婦仲良くするためには
互いにものすごく仲良く
もう理解し合って生活しなくちゃいけないと
ありえない話なんですけど
それでありえないことに頑張っちゃったら
苦しくて終わっちゃうでしょうね
ウサギにいくら栄養を食べさせても
角が出てこないでしょうに
だから牛が食べるもの
鹿が食べる食べ物を調べて調べて
鹿だったら立派な角があるんではないかと
やっぱり鹿食べるものはウサギにも食べさせましょうと言って
奈良に行って なんかせんべいありますね
鹿用の それでも大量に買ってきて
自分の家で飼っているウサギに食べさせても
ウサギは当然食べますよ
それは しかし出てこないんですよ
だからありえないことには
もう知識人はチャレンジしません
人間はチャレンジする
仏教は全くそういうありえないことにチャレンジしない
ただ事実を知って落ち着く
そういうふうに私たちの人生でなんで苦しいのかということを見てみると
こうやって我々は無理
ありえないことをいろんなありえないこと
たくさんありますよ そういうものにもチャレンジをする
だから 夫婦のところか
自分の子供のことも理解できない
知らないことっていうのはいっぱいある
それで終了なんですけど
そんな問題こと 世の中っていうのは
これが大変だと思うのは
自分の高慢でわがままで支配欲なんですね
子供のこと全然知らない
あ これが大変やと もし警察にと呼ばれたところで
これあなたの子供ではないか
こんな悪いこと今もういくつかやってるんだよと
あんた知らないんだよと言ったら
あ これ申し訳ないと引くぶんですよ
私だったら引っ込まない
だから何ですかと 知るわけないでしょうと
何やってるかと 私に言ってみたら
私は逆にもう言いますけど
あんた知ってますか？自分の子供のこと
そんな気にすることじゃないでしょ
何か問題を起こしちゃったら
それなりに処理しなさいよと
私まで責めるんじゃないよと
で そうやって事実を言うと
まあ問題っていうのはものすごい簡単に淡々と解決しています
悪いことした子供も まあそれで理解してしまう
母を困らせた 困らせた分で悪いことしたら全然困らない場合はね
自分がやめるんですよ
で 子供っていうのは 母っていうのはすごい独裁者で
ものすごい支配欲で えらい病気っていうことはわかってるんだからね
優しいっていうことはなくなって
恐ろしくなって すごい支配欲で子供を育てるんだから
子供はそれ知ってますよ
病気だと それで万引きでもしたらね
とんでもなく困るでしょうと思って
まあどうせそれで困りますからね
で またまたやる でも病気でない母だったら誰が気にするもんか
そんなの 私は困りませんよとね
言うと 向こうはすごい怖くなって
やっぱり自分の人生は自分で作らなきゃ
このお母さんが全然 全然平気だよとわかると
自分で自分責任持つということになるんで
ですから支配欲っていうのはね
ない方が正しい しかし両親にはそれが無理っていうことになってるんですね
愛ではなくて愛情になっているし
自分のものに所有物にしようとするしね
それでありえないことをしようとする
生命には他の生命を支配することはできません
こういう支配しているような錯覚だけで
世の中みんなそれぞれ独立していますよ
それ認めない世界で支配支配ばっかり喋って
それで宗教になってくるともっとひどいもの
それ正当化するんですよ
あのでたらめのインチキを
全ての生命を創造して支配し
管理する 慈しみのみを持っている絶対的な存在があるぞと
この普通の日本語で神様ということなんですけど
そうやって このまあとんでもない
このありえない嘘をもう観念の世界で作ってしまって
さらに人間不幸にしちゃうんですね
そうすると人間が 人が人を支配することっていうのは当たり前やと思っちゃうんですよ
それで凶暴な人々は 私は神に選ばれたんだと
あんた方を支配するために
政治学なんか勉強するときは
皆様聞いたことあるでしょうね
あの 政治システムがなぜ現れるかということにいくつか学説がありますね
一つは 神様がそうやって人間を誰か誰か王様として支配者として選んでいるんだよという
このもうそういう説もあります
それは誰も認めてないんですけど
政府っていうものが なんか国民を支配するものやと
という概念から脱却してないんですよ
政治論を語る人々の できるもんだったら支配してみろということですよ
誰も誰 誰にも誰を支配することできないんですよ
ですから 事実はみんな精神的には自分は一人別な人間だと
生命だと思っているんです
それで体ついてるんだから
体っていうのはすごい
もうまあ鈍くてのろくてもうもう弱いもんだから
それは簡単に体はつかめますけどね
飛んでる鳥を捕まるのは簡単なことですよ
しかし 気持ちを自分の方に向いてくるということはそう簡単じゃないんです
鳥を檻に飼って飼っておいたっても
鳥の心は外にあるんですよ
それが正しいやというのはどういうことかと
ただ自分騙されてるだけでしょうに
飼ってる鳥に餌をあげて水をあげて
いろいろ面倒見て まあ自分が飼ってるんだと
本当は飼ってないんですよ
ただ鳥に餌をあげてるだけなんです
人間の関係でも 私はそういう人々を管理しているんだよとかね
私は支配しているんだよ
私は支配者だよとかね
私は政府だよと でも何の力もないんですよ
例えば 法律的には大臣という人には
その仕事の内容の中では一番上の人ですけど
何の力もないでしょうに
首相といえばもうすべての力が自分の中にあるはずなんですけど
しかし何もできん それが正しい事実なんです
だから支配できないということは事実であって
このみんなどこで間違うかと
この頭が悪いんだから間違うのは当たり前なんですけど
知りたがるだけなんですけど
何も知ってないんだからね
この法則というものは世の中にありますから
それ勝手に物事動くわけじゃないんですよ
私はわかりやすく言うのは
リンゴの種まいてカボチャ食べたいと思ったっても
カボチャ食べるわけじゃないでしょうし
あるいはカボチャの種まいてじゃあリンゴ食いたいと思っても
出てくるのはカボチャだけでしょうし
だから そういうふうに私たちは自由でありながら
誰一人も自由でないというところがあるんですよ
その自由でないということは
誰かに支配されているというとんでもない考え方をしちゃうんですよ
生命は誰でも全然自由がありません
それがあらゆる法則の中で生きているということなんです
水飲まなきゃどうなるんですかね
死んでしまうでしょうに
だから自由じゃありませんよ
しかし 私が水を飲むんだから
誰かに支配されているというのはどういう話ですかね
それは 人間は呼吸しなかったらすぐ死ぬんですよ
だから自由はありません
宇宙に行っても呼吸するために酸素を持っていかないと
だから自由ではありません
だから支配されている
支配することもできるという
これはとんでもない錯覚でというか
錯覚というか おかしい誤解もいいところですよ
で 仏教の見方っていうのは
淡々と事実をありのままに見て
あらゆる法則があるんだぞと
結局は何一つ法則に成り立ってないものは何一つもないんではないか
というふうに因果法則論を語るんであって
絶対的神創造者ということっていうのは
もう笑ってしまいますよ
そんなのはもうまともな人を考えることじゃないんだと
それポイントをわかっていただければありがたいんですけど
で 私たちはやっぱり自由でありながら自由じゃないし
自由じゃないっていうことは
誰かに支配されているわけではなくて
あらゆるすべて法則のものですからね
心臓には心臓の法則があって
腎臓には腎臓の法則があって
血液には血液の法則があって
それぞれ法則によって仕事をして
それで腎臓も心臓も胃もいろんな組み合わせたところでまた別な法則が成り立ったりして
全部法則ですよ 例えばきれいな服着ましょうと思っても
何を着たってもきれいになるわけじゃないでしょうに
法則があるんですよ きれいかないか決めるのは同じ人間だから
人間の目の中で 知識の中できれいという感情がどのように生まれるかっていうことはまた決まってるんですよ
だから我々はいくらおしゃれしたってもワンパターンですよ
例えば鳥なんか綺麗でしょ？鳥の羽をたくさん作って
それで服を着ていると
まあ何か面白いもので見るしか服で見ないでしょうね
時々催し物なんかでは
鳥の形をしている人やら
ゾウのぬいぐるみを作って
その中に入り込んでいる人なんかいるんですけど
あんなのは遊びだけで終わっちゃいますよ
だから人間の目には体中羽がついてるとすごいかっこいいってことは見えません
だから今着ている服になってるんです
そういうことで あらゆるすべてのものはそれぞれ法則があるんだよと
その法則を理解する人っていうのはすべて知ってるんだよというお釈迦様の言葉になってるんですね
だからお釈迦様はよくサッバヴィドゥハマスミ
そういう言葉を言ってるんですね
サッバヴィドゥ すべて知ってますよ
私は こうですね サッバヴィドゥハマスミっていうのは
こっちアハンっていうのが私が
こちらアハン私がということで
アスミということで サッバヴィドゥすべて知ってる人でありますと
私は一切を知っている人でありますと
それは単なる宗教的な言葉ではありません
私は神であるというふうな言葉でもありません
サッバって何なのかと
お釈迦様はこの存在のことやと
生命のことやと それが法則によって成り立っているんだぞと
その法則を発見しましたから
仏教の言っている因果法則というのはそういうものだから
まあ知らないものは何一つもないんだよと
それしかないんだから
そういうことで 私たちは法則というものを知っているならば
まあ全部知ったことになります
それ法則知ると結構落ち着きます
うん はい それから次に
なんで人間が逃避するんですかと
事実から というポイントなんですね
事実から逃避するっていうことは
やっぱり本当のことを知りたくないんですよ
本当のことを知りたいで言っちゃうと
もう何も知らなくなっちゃうし
もう馬鹿みたく攻撃しちゃうし
それで結局互いに騙されて終わっちゃうし
だからこの本当のことを知りたいというこの気持ちを
ものすごく怪しいんですね
私たちが本当のことを知りたいと思ってはいるんですけど
その気持ち自体がすごく怪しいんです
それまた客観的に観察してほしいんです
世の中の生命が本当のことを知りたいならば
みんな本当のこともとっくに知ってるはずでしょうに
人類っていうのは随分長い間
もういろいろなことを勉強して
知識を獲得して 後の時代に残しているんだから
私たちにはまあ 1年ぐらいやれば
今までの人間の 年の知識を得られることできますから
もしすべての人々が本当のことを知りたがって頑張ったならば
もうとっくにみんな本当のことを知ってるはずなんです
しかし 違うんですね 本当のことを知りたいということがすごく怪しいんですね
疑わしい だからはっきり答え出しますが
私たちは本当のことは知りたくないんです
私が私の都合によって
自分の心にある欲と怒り
そういうものに油をさして
その炎に油をさしてくれるものを欲しいんですよ
いわゆる無知で 欲で 怒りで
怠けて生きてるんですよ
それから欲っていうのは
この 生きてること 大変楽しいや
楽しいやとかね いわゆるこの刺激ありますね
目から入る 耳から鼻から入るあらゆる刺激がありますね
そんなのはまあ楽しい
なんて楽しいかとかね
それも錯覚なんですけど
そういうふうにこの快楽みたいな妄想がありまして
この快楽妄想の中にいたいんですよ
その快楽妄想にさらに妄想できるように
情報を知りたいんです
ですから 人が本当のことを言っても
聞く人は聞かない それは自分で逆さまにして入れてあげるんです
だからデータっていうのは
このコンピューターと同じ
この小さな粒で来るんですよ
例えば 私は人と喋っていると
その人の体形っていうのは
体形だけ目にデータとして入る
音は耳に入ると それで
あ その人のことを知ってるんだぞと言ったっても
その人のデータが入ったわけじゃないんですよ
人を見て喋ってはいるんですけど
その人に対する一切のデータが入ったわけじゃないんです
その人の形が目に入ってきて
で 音は耳に入ると だからデータっていうのはそうやってこのコンピューターデータと同じく
それぞれ違った波動のいくつかの信号が入るだけ
その信号が私は自分勝手で
体心の中で組み立てる
かけて組み立て 組み立てて自分の都合のいい現象ですね
ものを作るんですよ  わかりやすい例で言います
ブロックありますね 子供は遊ぶ
その人がたくさんブロックを持ってきて
何か作ります 建物か飛行機か何か作っておいて
子供に君もこのブロックで遊んでくださいと言うと
子供に教えるのはこれ
もう自分で組み立てて遊んでくださいということなんです
それで子供はあのブロックを全部外しちゃうんですね
外して自分で組み立てる
その時は子供は前の飛行機でも後ろでも建物組み立てるんじゃないんですよ
自分にできること 自分に好きなことを組み立てるんですよ
そういうふうなことです
我々常にやっているのは
だからジグソーパズルを全部ピースに粉々に砕いて
それで自分好きなもので組み立てるんですね
同じものは組み立てません
それ我々知っているジグソーパズルっていうのははめないんですね
違うものは違うところに
しかし はめるものはいくらでもあります
例えば 1000 ピース
1500 ピースぐらいのジグソーパズルを見てください
はめますよ 違うものも
なぜかというと 形というのはそんなにたくさんないんだから
もしジグソーパズルの場合は
線が切った線は全部同じだったらどうしますか？そうすると
どんなピースもどんなピースつなげるでしょうね
その場合はもう人がどんなものを作るかっていうことはもうわかったもんでなくなっちゃいますね
で 私たちは世の中のデータっていうのはほんのわずかしか体に入ってこないんです
それで自分好きなものを心の中で描く
でも描くといったら形になりますから
私たちは現象という言葉を使います
心の中で自分好きな現象を作る
だから外から音の情報が入ると
みんな同じことを聞いてないんですよ
自分の頭で合成します
だから人を言ったか人が言ったことよく理解しましたとは
こんな威張って言えることじゃないんですよ
自分で合成します それは明らかでしょう
例えば この話が同じ話でも
例えば子供も聞いている子供の中で女の子も聞いている
男の子も聞いていると
大人の人々も聞いている
若い人々も聞いているという仮定してみましょう
私は同じことを喋っているんだけど
そのその人が何を理解するかと
別々なものを理解するでしょうに
で 私たちにはそれしかできん
もし中学生が私の話を聞いていたならば
その人の頭の中でどんな現象が起きるか
起きてどのように理解するかということは
我々は分かったものじゃないんですよ
それで私は今喋っているんだけど
皆様がどこまでどのようにその言っていることは理解しているかということはわからないんですよ
それで私たちは知識といっても
結局は自分の都合によって自分の貪瞋痴が燃えてくるような現象を作るんですね
それを現象と言ってもよろしいし
幻想幻覚だと言ったっても構いません
だって本当のとこと違いますからね
それだから我々は本当のことを知りたくはない
本当のことを言うと逃げる
そんなことを言うなかれと言って逃げます
簡単でしょう 例えば人が人に向かっても
あんたはそろそろ死ぬんじゃないかとか言ったら
それはすごい失礼でしょうに
本当のことを言ってはいけないんですよ
お元気なことと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
あれが嘘なんです しかし
それは聞きたいんでしょ？全然年見えないんですね
とかね で それが聞きたがっていることで
私たちの心の中にあるあの幻覚にぴったしはめるんですね
例えば歳 の男の人が来て
私に私は歳ですよと言った
もし私がね ああ そろそろあなたの体
これから壊れますよと
その体力も その知識も
これからもう何て言いますか
もう 立体立体に 何て言いますか
え？まあ これから落ちていくことだよと
それは事実でしょうね
でも二度と口きかないんで
そんなこと言ったら その人は
それで私は何言うべくかというと
人生はこれからですよと
何？まだまだ若いんではないかと
というふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで自分の心の中にあるイメージにぴったしなんですよ
だから口が上手な人っていうのは事実を語っている人じゃないんですよ
相手のイメージにぴったしのものを言うだけで
そんなのは単純 決まってます
人間何考えてるかということは貪瞋痴しかないんだから
あまりにも単純ですよ
だから世の中で口がうまい人
上手な人っていうのはものすごい簡単
そんな能力必要ではありません
皆様を騙して万円ぐらい何か取るということはいとも簡単ですよ
あらゆる複雑なことをしなくする必要な
バレるでしょう もう一周
1ヶ月間で万円が騙し取ったとか
号億円騙し取ったとか
いとも簡単な手口で それ
私たちの弱みを握ってますよ
我々は貪瞋痴の人族 何かイメージ持ってますからね
そのイメージに合えばよろしいんですよ
お年になった方に例えばいくらか例えば貯金があるとする
それでもその人は欲があると
自分の将来は心配しているということがわかっちゃうと
こんなの当たり前だから
そんなにわかる必要ないでしょうに
そんなのは それでこんな銀行に貯金して置いたって
今銀行潰れますよと それで潰れると
お金戻ってこないんだけど
一部しか 新しい法律変えましたからね
ですから それはもうちゃんと生かして
具体的に毎月毎月これぐらいの収入があった方が貯金よりはいいんじゃないかと
これで一生 もう我々約束しますと
死ぬまで毎月毎月これぐらい収入入るようにと
今問題は誰にもないんだから
年経ってから ちょうど 2年満期になったら
毎月毎月 ２０万か 30 万がずっと払ってるんだと
それで計算してくださいと頼むんですよ
これからまあ今は 70 歳だからね
もしかすると もしかすると
まあ今元気でしょうし
まああともう軽々く 20年ぐらいは得られるんだと
軽々計算で 20年ぐらい
20 万で計算してみてください
貯金よりは入ってるんだ
そしたら あ なるほどと言ってお金出しちゃうでしょうに
その人は 2年満期満期になる前に
もう半年間で重症なくどこに行ったかわからなくなっちゃいますからね
そういうふうなことで人を騙すっていうことはとっても簡単なやり方
簡単に騙されます どんな人でも
なんででしょうかというと
私たちは本当のことを知りたくない
私たちの心の中にあるこのイメージ
それをそれに刺激する
それは正当化することだけ考えているんですね
だから自分勝手に情報を入れ替える
それでこのいろんなこのコマーシャルなんかを見てみると
みんなこれこそ素晴らしいものやと言って飛んで買っちゃいますけど
コマーシャル作る人々も鋭いんですよ
なぜかというと 誰かが訴えちゃうと
もう嘘の約束して品物を売ると
全部払わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますよ
ですから このなんか飾り文句いっぱい書いてますけど
読んでみるとすぐわかるんですね
何も言ってないと その見ると
すごい賢いなと私は思いますよ
こんな宣伝文句見たら
この品物を買う必要ないんだと
という冗談で言いますけど
逆に書いた人が鋭い 誰かが訴えたって訴えられない
我々はそんな約束してないんだと平気で言えるんです
例えば もう 2週間で 5 キロ減ったとかね
そういうダイエットの効果がありますよとかね
そういうものをものすごく丁寧に読んでみてください
これを飲んだら必ずもこういう風になりますという風にはない
結論出てこないんです
うまく作るんですよ 時々誰かさんの証言
誰かさんの証言 誰かさんのどこの誰かとさっぱりわからんでしょ
そういう風に この私たちはその情報を見て自分勝手に解釈するんだから
やっぱり買った人の負けなんですよ
どうしようもないんですよ
そういうことで 私たちは本当のことを知りたくはない
それが悪くなってくるとかなり悪くなりますよ
例えば誰かと何か気に入らなくなっ
そういう怒りが出てきます
何かケンカになったり
なんとかなって 怒りが出てきますね
そうすると その人が悪いと
とんでもないと 信頼できないと
裏切り者やと というふうな結論があればもっと怒れるでしょ？楽しく
それでその人のことを調べて調べて
そういうふうに解読するんです
で わかりやすい例に戻ります
例えば旦那さん嫌になったと
嫌になったところで まあ旦那さんが裏切り者で浮気者で金無駄遣いするんで
家に収入は持ってこないでとかいろいろあった方が嫌になるためにいくらでも証拠なんですよ
それで旦那のことを調べると
自分勝手に 何のために調べるかというと
この人は嫌な人やと 別れた方がいいと自分を説得するために情報を探すんですよ
それに結婚したその日からも
この人はもしかすると
朝起きてどこかへ出かける可能性あります
気に入っている時はまあどこかへ出かけたんだ
それで終わっちゃいます
気に入らなくなった あれ
どこに出かけるんですかね？これが怪しいと
一度も出かけると どこに行くかと私に言ったことはないんだと
何のこともなく あの同じ情報を自分の都合により解釈するんですよ
仲が良い時は あの人は元気で
もう朝起きたらすぐもう１時間後 ２
時間もう出て行っちゃったら帰ってこないよと
もうなんとかやってるでしょ
男だからと そういうのを明るく見ていて
逆になったらどこに行ってるんでしょうかと
これが怪しいと いうの同じデータを自分の都合によって解読する
そういうことだから 私たちの判断というのは全くも当てにならないんですよ
でも 我々は自分で見て
自分で考えて 自分で判断して生きているでしょうに
しかし 人間がやっている判断というのは一つも当てにならない
すべて主観であって 自分だけの考え方であって
それはまた自分の都合によって怒っている時は悪いと判断する
楽しい時はいいと判断する
子供のことを気に気に入っている時は
子供がうるさくキャーキャーと遊んでいると
やっぱり楽しいと なんて元気な子ですかと
うちの子はふうに喜んでいて
自分の機嫌が悪い時はうるさいと
なんで音 なんて静かにしてくれないかと
なんで他の子供みたいにちゃんともう育ててくれないかと
同じことを同じく言うんですよ
だから自分言うことっていうのは全くも当てにならない
それが大変なことで理解してほしいんですよ
だから我々は本当のことを知っているわけでもないし
知りたくもない 逆にそれから逃げて
自分だけの世界を作って
入ってくるデータを強引に自分で組み立てる
だから象のデータが入ったら
心の中でウサギの現象を組み立てる可能性はあります
そういうふうに覚えておけば理解しやすいんですよ
入ったのは象のデータですけど
私は見たのはウサギですよと
そんな感じで変えちゃうんですよ
それがこの小さな子供の遊びでよく見えますよ
で 子供に大体私は観察しているのは男の子ばっかりなんですけど
で いろいろおもちゃとかありますね
おもちゃを作る人々は何かの遊びを考えて作っているんですよ
しかし このちっちゃな男の子たちにこのおもちゃをあげたら
この会社が設計した 考えた使い方はしないんですよ
別な使い方をするんです
だからそれ見てると大体大人がちゃんとちょっと困りますけど
せっかくこういうふうに遊んでほしいということで
もう買ってあげたおもちゃなんですけど
そんな親が考えた遊びはやってくれないんですね
私は自分の親戚の子供に男の子なんですけど
で まだ幼稚園には行ってない
で いろんなものにすごい興味はある
そこで向こうでないすごい出来のいい小さなちっちゃな車
車ありますね で それがすごくいいものをセット買ったんですよ
向こうで 1個だけ買っていったって
向こうはそれさえないし
向こうのおもちゃ また別なそんなにいいものもないし
で 日本から考えちゃうと
子供っていうのはおもちゃが小さければ小さいほど喜ぶんですよ
まあそれも観察してるの男の子ばっかりだから
このポケットに入れて
2つ  3つぐらい入れて持っていきたいんです
ただそれだけ で ポケットに子供のポケットだから
やっぱりそれぐらい小さい方が
まあもうポケットに入れて膨らませてまあいるんです
だから後ろのポケットに入れて
まあ両側も入れちゃって
で まあそれがその小さい子供
楽しいんですね そういうことで
小さなものもないんだから
10個かもっとあったかな
まあセットも買っていったんですね
それでそれが見たある大人の男の人っていうのはびっくりしたんですよ
この性能の良さというかね
すごい で ちょっと触って
ちょっと触って外しちゃうと
ものすごいスピードで走るんですよ
まあそちらの軍隊のところなんですけど
まあまあ軍人ばっかり
その人 ある若い子が来て
これがブレーキないねと私に言うんですよ
もうブレーキないおもちゃばっかりで
全部大人までびっくりするんだけど
このスピードやら性能やら
もうあまりにもよくできちゃって
私はまあそれよりは肝心なね
まあ子供がどう面白がってるか
全然面白がらないんですね
それでもって何したんですかというと
タイヤ全部外したんです
10個ですから もうタイヤがもう 40個あります
ここで両手でこんな大量に
持ってきて それみんなにはいはい
どうぞと  10分も経たないうちに全部外したんだ
そうと威張るんですよ
それだけではなくて 次にこのタイヤのゴムを外しちゃうんですよ
だから大人から見ればなんてことするんだ
こんなにこれ タイヤ外して
これあっちこっち捨てちゃうとね
それも無駄になるんではなくて
やっぱりその子にはその子の世界があるんですよ
そこでそのお父さんと私は
まあまあ どこ我々のカサコっていうのは
いつでもすごいからかってる言葉を言うんですよ
お父さん来て あ こいつは過去生でタイヤの泥棒でもやっていたでしょうか
こいつはまあもうどこかこの
人の子供のタイヤでも盗んで売ったりして商売でもやっていたんじゃないですかとかね
それでまあ我々笑っちゃう
笑ったんですけど やっぱりこれ見ていられないんですね
もう何を買ってあげたっても
すぐタイヤ外すっていうことはします
だから我々わからないのは
その子の頭の中でどんなイメージあるかと
だからそれを見て何を理解するかというと
世間のデータがどうであろうとも
私たちは自分の都合によって理解して
自分の世界を作るんだということなんです
この間も日本のまた子供を見ていたんですけど
どんなおもちゃあっても
この人がドカーンドカーンドカーンと全部もう落としちゃうんです
他の兄弟 いろいろ組み立て作ったら全部壊しちゃうんです
ドカーンドカーンって言って
何もできん どんなおもちゃでもドカーンって言って壊しちゃう
で それ知ってます なぜかというと
だいたいこの工事現場とかね
そういうシャベルカーやら
そういうすごい音を出すものっていうのは興味あるんです
だからすごい音を出して
土を叩いたり いろんなことをやったりする機械ありますから
まあそれが頭の中にあって
自分のドカーン遊びに他のおもちゃを全部使う
で そんなもんで だからそれを子供がやってること
同じこと 我々はずっとやってます
それ 子供がこの設計した決まってる遊びがやると楽しいなのに
例えばスイッチ入れてハンドルを回しながら動ける車なんか買ってあげても
これドカンドカンしちゃうとかなり高価な
かなり値段も聞きますからね
そういう車とかはね 音
両親にとって困るでしょうしね
もうちゃんと乗って クラクションやらいろいろ鳴らしながら
あっちこっちあっちこっち乗っていった方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
それは使わない そんなことには
こちらの子はドカーン使っちゃうし
自分の親戚の子だったらもうタイヤ外す
で そのパターンっていうのは
人間悟らない限りは終わらないんですよ
技術は知りたくはない
自分の世界に閉じ込まれていたいと
だからなんですよ 輪廻転生する生命には成長がありませんと
そのサイクルを破らない限りは同じところで回っているんだぞというのは
そういうことで 私たちは事実から逃避して逃げる
では事実って何ですかね
人が生まれたら必ずしも死ぬ
死ぬということは何なのかというと
やっぱりこれあるシステムだから
このシステムが崩れてしまう
機能しなくなる そんなのはどんな道具にも同じことで
車は作ったら必ず壊れるということで
永遠には使えません 車を作る会社は
ちょうど 5年目で壊れるように作っているんです
そこまで何問題ないんです
一応 3年では それから問題を起こしますが
3年だけまではぴったしなんです
で  5年目になってくったらからもうあれこれと問題が起こる
で 修理工場に持って行ったっても
これはね まあこれぐらいお金かかります
新しいものに変えたらどうですかと
という新しいものに変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
で 作る人もそんな感じなんですよ
でもそれ言っちゃうと誰も買いませんよ
だから何言うかというと
最高な技術 世界一流の技術
それまたコンピューター制御とかね
それまたこれもついていて
これもついていて 何か文句あるかと
そんな風に言うんですよ
だから言ってること本当のことじゃないんです
で だから人が生まれたら死ぬ
壊れる それで壊れるまでの人生なんですよ
ですから 生きるということはどんどんどんどん悪くなる一方であって
決して良くなるということはあり得ないんです
しかし 生まれた時も悪いでしょうに
生まれた赤ちゃんそれでいいわけじゃないでしょうに
もう人間扱いできないんです
何もできない ということは
生まれる時も悪いんですよ
ものすごい不完全で 何もできない
生きることさえもできない
とんでもないやつが生まれるんですよ
自分で生きることさえもできない
だから生まれた時もそんな調子で
それから修理始めるんですよ
この壊れた 壊れて買った機械を
だからこれ買うことではありませんだけど
生まれる時ももうもう重体で
もう故障状態 それでもいろいろいじって修理して修理して
もうなんとかなんとか歩けないことは歩けるようにする
喋れないことは喋れるようにする
おっぱいしか飲めないものには固形物
硬いものでも食べられるようにするとかね
すごい丁寧にそこは修理しますよ
例えばご飯食べるまでどれぐらいかかりますかね
その間は それでうまくいくかというと
うまくいかないんですよ
いつでも故障状態で また修理しなくちゃいけない
そんなことで年取っては死ぬ
ですから 明るいイメージが立たないのは正しいんですよ
子供が生まれたら大変だと思うことが正しいのに
我々は「おめでとうございます」と言うんです
お釈迦様だけなんですよ
あんたにも子供が生まれた
あ 大変だと言ったのは
とんでもないことになったと
お釈迦様はラーフルージャーとバンダナンジャータン
ラーフルっていうのは迷惑
すごい迷惑なものを生まれたんだと
バンダナンジャータン束縛が生まれたんだと
だって最悪な状態で生まれるでしょうに
それからもうずっと修理しなくちゃいけないんだから
親が 釈迦さんが出家するちょっと前に子供が生まれたそうでって報告された時はそれを言ったんです
私たちだったら何言うんですかね
だから我々はなんでしょうかね
知ってる世界っていうのは
なんて素晴らしいことではないか
おめでとう 会社で電話がかけてきたら
もう会社のみんなはその場で祝福するでしょうに
だから 我々の本当の世界と我々の知りたがる世界っていうのは
随分もう全く正反対で
正反対でいいならばいいんだけど
それで大変でしょうし
苦しみも悩み 怒り 戦争
何から何まで我々のこの誤った知識から生まれるもんでしょうに
だから頭を直してみなさいと
それで人が生まれることも苦しみ
苦しくて不完全で それからもずっと苦しみを味わいながら
それからどんどん苦しみながら
もう嫌で死んでしまいますよと
そんなのは不完全で虚しい
苦しいものだと見なさいよという真理の第１番目
すべてはドッカである
これが事実ですよと お釈迦様はおっしゃっているのに
誰一人ももう耳を傾けないんですね
お釈迦様 これを知ったらすべての苦しみが消えちゃって
完全な安らぎを体験できますよと
しかし 知ろうとはしないっていうのは
まあ人間の問題なんです
事実 別にそんなに大変隠れているわけじゃないんですよ
データっていうのは いくらでもそこら中がありますよ
事実だから 真理だから
真理は隠れるわけじゃないんです
発見する必要もないんです
もう堂々とあるんです
しかし 見えないってことはすごい面白いんですよ
例えば この部屋にゾウが来たら
ものすごいでっかい動物でしょうに
どこどこと見えないと
どう言えばいいんですかね
ゾウがどこにいるんでしょうかねとかね
調べてみたところ あ やっぱりいないと決めちゃうと
だから仏教は当たってない人には愚か者やと
無知な人やというのは
そういうことで使っているんです
あるのに 隠れてないのに
例えば我々の人生 ずっと丁寧に観察してみてください
すごく満足感 充実感ということを感じたことがあるのかと
あるいはもっとやりたいとかね
これではダメやとかね
もっとしっかりしなくちゃとかね
というふうな気持ちでいることと
どっちですかね 我々は
いつでも不安感で 不満で悩まされているでしょうね
それが我々は逆に解釈する
もっと運動しなくちゃ
もっとダイエットしなくちゃ
もっといい仕事をしなくちゃ
もっと勉強しなくては
もっと子供に優しくしなくては
もっと奥さんのことを理解してあげなくては
そういうふうにリストがあるでしょうに
あの 何といいますか これからやるべき仕事のリスト
ということは 今不満ということなんですよ
そのリストから解放された瞬間ありますか？この数えられないほどのやらなくてはいけないリスト
things to do
英語では簡単です だから私は完成した仕事
それからやらなくてはいけないことというふうに 2つに分けてみると
完成したものというのは一つも見つからないと思いますけど
だからこの things to do というリストっていうのはもう無数にありますよ
それが人間が不満でいるということなんです
それは楽しくないということなんですよ
もっと良い仕事をしなくちゃと思ったところで
何感じていますかね やったことについては納得いってないんですよ
それが人生なのに見ようとしない
それ隠れていますか？その感情が
隠れているわけじゃないでしょう
朝晩念じていますから
しかし あのほんのわずかな思考の回転
やっぱり人生っていうのはどこまででもそんなもんではないかと
こんなやらなくちゃあかんことっていうのは終わるわけがないんではないかと
これって何なのかというと
死にたくなくなっている自分
負けたくなくなっている自分
今までの幸福に不満を感じている自分というもの
自分見えるはずなんです
それが渇愛というんですよ
真理の第2番目 それがすべての生命にある絶対的な唯一の真理なんです
生きることは苦しみであることと
渇愛がこの苦しみをどんどんどんどん無限に無制限に続けちゃうということ
その真理 2つは絶対見ないっていうのは生命の声
だからいい加減で 本当のことを知りたいと言うなよっていうのは
私たち言いたい立場なんですよ
そんなインチキ嘘を言うなよと
私たちにとって 何か都合が良いと思ったら
その情報だけ言ってくれというだけなんですよ
例えば 日本人というのは北朝鮮に対して何の興味も持ってないんです
何の興味も持ってない
しかし 拉致された人々のことはしっかり教えてくれと
弁償弁償というので その場合は損害賠償
何でしたっけ えっ 損害賠償しなさいと
それしか知ろうとしない
もし北朝鮮人があんた方は我々の国民が何人ぐらい拉致したんですかと
戦争の時は我々は何人殺したんでしょうかと聞いたらどうですかね
それ聞きたくないでしょ
日本軍隊が北朝鮮に行ってやったこと
どれぐらい人間は日本に強引に強制で連れてきたと
どれぐらいの人をシベリアまで連れてきて死なせたか
死なせたかというと だからその事実は知りたくない
そんなのは忘れろと平気で言うんです
もう我々は関係ないんだと
もう違いますよと という風に
だからまあ 仏教を知っている人は
そういう場合は誰の肩も取って取らないで落ち着いているんですよ
だから私から見ればどちらも悪いんですよ
大国家たる国が そこら辺の一般のどれか
女の人とか若者とか拉致して
これは恥もいいところなんですけど
日本の大臣一人でも拉致するんだったらやれと言いたいんですよ
そうすると国には力があるということがわかるんだから
日本の総理大臣にも拉致したら
なかなかやるもんだなと
そこら辺で海岸でそこら辺に行っている人は
店にいる人はそのまま持って
何の力もない一般人でしょうに
だからもうなんて情けないというか
だからそれからやられる側の苦しみ
悩みっていうのは また並大抵のものじゃないし
家族がね もう悲しむことやら
また探しにも方法も何もない状態っていうのは
親にとって親戚にとってはすごい悲しみ
悲しむことでしょうし
それも良くないし しかし
こちらやったことも同じ苦しみ
悲しみでしょ みんな同じ人間だからね
だから人間っていうのは
自分の都合によって良いことだけ知りたがる
その時狂暴で教えてくれと
ただでは済まんぞと という風な
曲げていく もう一度イラクを潰してやるぞとかね
やってるでしょうに すべて自分の都合
都合っていうのは だからブッシュさんがもう誰か爆弾を落とさないとなかなか人気ないみたいですね
それで一つすごい人やというすごい人気が出てきて
日本の小泉さんとほとんど同じぐらい
だから 3000人死んだところで
その人は儲かっちゃったんですよ
それも誰も言わない 私以外は
テロ事件で 3000人以上死んじゃったところで
ブッシュさんが政治的に自分の権力を確定しましたよと
考えてもそういう事実なんですけど
それでその人気が薄れていくと
ではイラクにやりましょうと
それで査察できれば イラクに爆弾を落とすことできなくなりますから
それ査察できないように
その国の態度を築くんですよ
そうすると向こうも腹が立って来るなよと言うんですね
だから査察らしい 調べますということで
という感じではいかないんですね
どうしても途中で追い返せるようなことをする
それでやっぱりやらなくちゃいかんということになりますね
そこで あの まだ決めてないんだから
大統領決めていって 民主の
何て言いますか デモクラティックパーティーの
あの  あの 何て言いますかね
コングレスの方はね  まだ決めてないんだから
この政治的なことを考えないで
国のことを考えてほしいと
ブッシュさんが言う それが事実かというとそうじゃないでしょう
自分の都合によって早く決めてくれと許可してくれという感じなんですね
それでではみんな 野党というかね
まあコングレスの方がいきなりそんなことを決めてはいけませんよと
というのも どちらかというと
やっぱりそちらが違う角度で見て
その方が自分たちにとっては都合がいいんですよ
やっぱり政治っていうのはそういうふうなもので
あの 明確に説明できないんですけど
あんまりやりたくはないし
やっぱり自分自分の都合で喋ってるだけなんですよ
では 随分時間経ちましたので
少々今日はちょっと計算できないんで
時計遅くなってきたんだから
ちょっと皆さん疲れたと思います
どうぞ 5 分ぐらい それで
この真理というものは
誰にも変えることも何もできない真理
真理なんです 事実は事実なんです
それで事実っていうのは
私の考え方とは関係ない
ものなんです ただ 私は人を見て綺麗な人だと思うことは私の勝手なことで
事実は別なものなんですね
それで私はある人を見て綺麗な人だと思うと
他の人はその人はそんなかっこいいわけじゃないと思う
だから二人が違う意見 2つ持ってます A
さんは綺麗な人ですと私が言う A
さんはかっこ悪い人ですと他人が言う
そうすると私と他人の間で意見違いが生じています
それで私たちは二人喧嘩しようとする
で 見たものと喧嘩したっても意味がないんだからね
しかし  A さんは何者かという何かあるでしょうに
だからその事実に事実は個人の思考とは関係ないんですよ
だから事実 真理というものは
私はわかりやすい例 いつでも同じ例を出していきます
地球が丸いということは真理で事実なんですね
そんなのは我々の主観とは何の関係もないんです
地球が丸い それは事実です
そうすると地球が丸いということにおいては
人間は喧嘩しません 異論は成り立ちません
何の問題も起きません
しかし 遠い昔 地球を知らなかった時代では
地球についていろんな考え方があったんですよ
その時はその間でいろんな喧嘩があったんです
例えばインドだったら隅千光でしょうし
５つの島があって 真ん中の島はインドで ５
つ ４つかな その真ん中
隅というものがあるとかね
上は天国があって 下は海で
海の上にこの島があって
海の下はなんかなんかもう最後にこの亀が全部もう背負っているとかね
それはインド人の世界観で
西洋に行っているとまた違う考え方で
互いに喧嘩したり 殺し合いまでやったりすると
しかし これが丸いと すみせんも何のこともなく
平らでもなく 丸いものだとわかっちゃうと
もう全部あの問題も異論も全部消えてしまう
ですから 真理を知ることで
すべての戦い 問題 悩み
苦しみ 消えるはずなんです
平和が成り立つはずなんです
だから どんなものについてあっても
真理を知るしか方法はないんですよ
それでなぜ私は苦しみかというと
真理知らないんだからなんですよ
なぜ私は喧嘩しているんですかと
人とはっきりわかってないんだからなんです
偏見で見ているんだからなんです
主観で見ているんだからなんです
ですから 真理を知るということはすごい大事なことで
それでみんな困ったと
大変だと そんな真理 すべて知られるわけじゃないと思っちゃうんですよ
それまた固定概念で だからその人そう思ってるだけで
私はあんた思ってるんだからって言って事実ではありませんと
なぜならば 我々のこの殻の中から我々思っている真理っていうのは逆さまだから
人の情報知りたいだけでしょうに
料理のレシピを探しているような感じで
それだったらいくら知ったっても知ったっても知り得るわけないでしょうに
子供のことを知りたいと思っても
知り得るわけがないでしょうに
それであんたすべて知ったら平和だと言ったっても
これ大変ではないか 無理ではないかと
子供のことでも知る不足知り尽くすことできんではないかと
しかし そんなことをいくら知ったっても偏見でしょうに
だから真理っていうのは
人のことを知ることでも何でもなく
法則を知ることなんですね
だからお釈迦様は淡々とそんなのを教えてるんですよ
すべては無常であると
変化しているんだと 瞬間だけだとなんだかんだでも組み合わせだと何でも
例えばバラの花が綺麗ですかと言えば
仏教では答えがありません
こちらで花があって バラの花が好きやと思う人間が見たら綺麗でしょうし
バラには何の興味もない人が立たせちゃうと
あのバラの花は綺麗でないという答えが出てくるし
だからバラの花が綺麗ということは
したもので 条件によって成り立つ
バラの花が好きな人がいて
その人がバラの花を見る時はバラの花が綺麗です
バラの花がすごい嫌な人がいて
その人の前でバラの花があると
バラの花が綺麗じゃないんです
だから バラの花に何か判断を出すということは
勝手に出してもいいんですけど
それは一時的な現象である
これ この白板は白いですか？ということは
はい 白いです 決まった事実と
そう言えるはずがないんですよ
今の条件の中で白いだけで
条件変わっちゃうと白くはないんですよ
じゃあ真っ暗闇でこれ白いんですかね？あるいは明かりが全部純粋に赤くなっちゃうと
これが白いですかね その場合は
あるいは違う世界に行って
そちらの光は X線しかないという世界を想像しましょう
ある世界があって そこの人々には X線はよく見えると
で そちらにこれを持っていったら
その人にこれ見えますかね
違う風に見えるでしょ
我々から考えると  X線は通ったりするし
もし鉄板とか何かあったらそこら辺でぶつかったりするし
だからそんな決めつけるということは良くない
すべてその一時的なものであると
味噌汁は美味しいやというのは正しくないんですよ
でも 世俗的に我々は美味しいと言うんだけど
やっぱり覚えてほしいんですよ
そういうものが一時的なことで
条件によるものやと だからそれぞれの人が好みの味噌汁っていうのはまた味が違うでしょうに
それはもう美味しいのは決まってるんだそうと思って
好き勝手に食べてみてください
美味しくないんですよ
あるいは水を普通の水
水 水に溶かして飲んでみてください
一生嫌いになるかもしれません
やっぱり出汁入れたりして
いろんな何か具を入れたりして
温かくて 味を調えて その人の好みによって
そうすると美味しいっていうことが成り立つんであって
そういうもので 物事に対する我々は
この何て言いますか この停止している判断していますね
動的じゃないんですよ
だから一切もう我々の知識っていうのは
いつでも動的なレベルで持っていかないと
ですから この人は可愛いとかね
この人は憎たらしいとか
いろいろ我々は診断 判断を出していったりしますが
そんなのは一時的 一時的
その条件の中だけですよと
条件から取っちゃうと全部崩れてしまいますよと
条件変わると全部崩れちゃいます
この部屋が明るいんですか？と言えば明るいんですよ
しかし スイッチ切った瞬間で暗くなってしまいます
そういう風にすべてのものはもうそんなことしかないんですよ
他のものっていうのは何も大したことではありません
ご飯がおいしいということでも
花が綺麗ということでも
あれやこれや 我々の知識世界っていうのは何のこともないものなんです
この一時的な条件ばっかり頭で叩いて込んで
一時的な条件っていうのは
どこまで叩いて叩き込んだっても切りがないでしょうに
例えば花に明かりを当ててみようと思ったら
我々にどれぐらい明かりを当てられますかね
数えられないでしょうね
光の主流に見ても電気明かりなんですけど
もう蛍光灯もあるわ スポットライトもあるわ
またそれまたいろいろ変えることできるわ
直接当たることもできるわ
反射させてさせることもできるとかね
それから上下 あっちこっちから光を当てることもできる
その当たるたびに バラの花が
花がそれぞれ違う顔で見えてくるんでしょうね
どんな顔も正しくないんですよ
あの いわゆるこの Fixed という英語で言えば結論が出てこないんですよ
変わらないという   バラの花について結論出しなさい
フィックスという変わらない決まり
結論として決定的に判断しなさいと言っても
決定フィックスの決定っていう意味でしょう
で それ出てこないんですよ
では 比較的にバラの花に光を当てて
一番いい顔を見せるのはどんな光の時ですか？と決めなさいと言ったとしても
それさえも決定的に言えないんですよ
あ この方が綺麗だと思うの
その人の主観だからね
だから何一つにも依存しない
執着しない方が心が自由なんですよ
我々 何か考え方 これこそ正しいやと思っちゃうと
その人がなんかこのもう強引にウイルス自分に打ってもらったような感じなんですよ
例えば全くの治療ない
必ずしも死んでしまう何かウイルスあるとしましょう
それがわざと自分で注射すると自分が苦しむでしょうに
ですから 私たちはあらゆる意見について
これが正しい これが正しいと思っていること
決定論で思っていることが
ものすごい限りない苦しみの元になっているんですね
ですから 一切の主観から脱出する
完璧に心をきれいにする
すべて無常であることをわかる
すべて条件の中で一時的に起こるものであるとわかる
私の奥さんは綺麗ですよと
そんなのは言うもんじゃないんですよ
本当は何時何秒で どんな時
どんな環境でということなんですよ
綺麗に見える だから綺麗に見えたことを別に
瞬間の感覚だからそれはいいんですが
その場合はもう何日 何時
何秒で どんな光の中で
どんな服装の中で どんな形でかと言った方が正しい
言いにくいんですけど
その時も互いの気持ちも必要ですよ
自分の気持ちが良い時は綺麗に見えるし
気持ちが悪い時は自分の奥さんが綺麗に見えませんしね
その時は平気で悪口言うでしょう
ですから うちの奥さんが綺麗ですよという場合でも
その相手が相手の機嫌が悪い時でも綺麗に見えないし
だから人のこの心の状況やら時間やら
何時何秒かって その瞬間で綺麗に見えたというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから本当はそういうことなんですが
だからこれがまとめて理解しておけば
すべて無常で その条件の中で一時的に成り立つものであると
例えば噴水があって 噴水の下にあらゆる明かり
照明を作っておく それで照明はいろんな制御で赤くなったり
青くなったり もう赤くなって止まる
瞬時に赤い青 いろんな色に変えたりとかしちゃうと
ものすごい別々に見えるでしょうに
いろんなところで公園とか
そういうふうに噴水の遊びがありますね
これど派手にシンガポールでやってますよ
ある一箇所で決まってる時間で
水を踊らしちゃうんですよ
音楽に合わせて で 大勢の人々が行って毎日見ています
で そういうところを見て
ああ すごい綺麗ということではなくて
そちらに仏教の真理があるんですね
やっぱり瞬間で一時的
ある時はある形で水が踊っちゃって
ある色で また音楽とともにまた形変わったり
また形変わったり また形変わったり
それで同時に光も水に与える
当てる光もいろんなことでもう変わって変わっていっちゃいますよ
かなり大きなスケールでやってます
それは それでまあ  15分か 20分ぐらいでそのショー終わっちゃいます
ですから この 20分のショーなんですけども
1 秒単位で全部変わっていく
だから美しいか美しくないか
何だかんだも人間の考える概念というのはもう判断
結論でありますから すべて動的であって
フィックス決定的にはならないんだと
一切は無常であるということをわかることが
すべての人間には究極的な平和をもたらす真理なんですよ
でも私たちはまあそうかということになってしまいますね
しかし それは変えられません
それが真理ですから だから仏教において修行する人やらね
理解する人々はみんな平和で
何の問題もなく豊かでいるんだよと
それで今日 私は本当にこの言葉についてもしゃべりたかったんですが
ですから 我々に役に立つものって何なのかというと
料理の研究をしてもしても
まあ仕事になるんだったら役に立ちますよ
金儲かるんだったら でもそれはほんの小さなことでしょうに
食べるためのぐらいのものでしょうに
ですから そこら辺でストップしてほしいんですよ
この知識を追っていくことは
まあ生きるためにはこれぐらいで十分やと
で それ以上知識を得れば得るほど馬鹿になってしまいますよ
だって知ることはすべて嘘だから
嘘をたくさん知っている
嘘を少ないという どちらでいいんですかね
だから世界の歴史やらあれやこれや
何だかんだも知ってるって人の頭っていうのは嘘ばっかり
膨らむ もう入れて 入れて
入れて 入れて入れて だからたくさん知るということは決してありがたいことじゃないんですよ
ただ適当に役に立つぐらいでストップする
しかし 知識がなければダメでしょうし
本当のことを知らなかったらダメです
それでお釈迦様はやっぱり選択しなさいと
こんな現象の世界 いくら知ったってももう終わりがないんだよと
知ったっても一時的なものだから
全然面白くもなんともないんだ
例えば ある食べ物を食べてものすごく美味しかったとしましょう
しかし その食べ物はこの地球で一つしかないと
とする たった一つしかない
それも食べる時は 1 日何も食べてはいけないと
でないとその美味しさ感じませんよと
それである人が 1 日食べないでいて
一個しか存在しない食べ物を食べたとする
その人においしかったとする
だから何ですか？人に言い触らす
あれおいしかった だから何ですかね
もうないんだから 覚えておく
レポートを書く 本を書く
その美味しさについて
一つ役に立たんでしょうに
そこでエピソードになる
物語になる 神話になる
そんなのいくら勉強しても読んでも役に立たんでしょうに
一回しか起こらなかった出来事だから
しかし すべてそんなもんですよ
すべて一回しか起きらない出来事なんですよ
そんなの覚えてどうするんですかね
役に立ちません そういうわけで
無常ということを成り立つのだから
それ知る人がすごい平和安らぎを感じるんだよと
一切の苦しみを落としてしまいますよと言っていて
だから喋るならば いくら喋っても意味がないんだと
人の苦しみ増えるだけやと
法句経法句経ダンマパダで言ってますよ
サハッサンピチェーワーチャ
千以上言葉を喋ったっても
アナッタパダサンギタ
何の意味も持てない 言葉千以上喋ったっても意味がない
エーカンアッタパダンセヨ
一つの言葉だけ喋れば
ヤンスッタウパサンマ
それで心が穏やかになる
平安になる一言葉に価値があるんだよと
それから作品 歌 詩なんかは 1000
以上作ったっても 瞬時に何の意味もないんだよと
アナッタパダサンギタ
一つの偈 一つの四行 二行
一行でも聞いて 人の心が安らぎを味わうならば
心の苦しみを落とす言葉だったら一言葉で十分だよ
そこで人間っていうのはそんな言葉ではなくて
感情で喋る だから喋っていることはすべて意味がありません
すべて嘘になっちゃう
それは心理的な嘘であって
嘘をついたという罪にはなりません
例えば 自分が感情で人に怒って
あんた何を醜いんだと
あれやこれやと言っても
それは自分の感情を言っているだけで
相手に対してあんた醜いんだよと
もうもう年で もういろんなことを侮辱の言葉を言っても
それは自分の感情を語っているんであって
その人はそう言ったわけではならないんですよ
だから言ってるようなことは嘘なんですよ
あんたバカですよというのは
こっちが怒ってるんですよ
だからその人バカですかね
それは違うでしょうし
で その場合も我々は嘘を言ってるんですよ
感情にやられて 感情に支配されて
しかし 感情に支配されていう言葉が
仏教の罪の中で嘘をついたとは言わないんです
それしか言えないんだから
言ってるだけで 気に入らなかった人が
あなたはうるさいと あんたと仲良くしたくないんだと
あんた見るだけでも腹が立ちますよというのは
その人の感情なんで事実ではありません
事実を語らんだからといって嘘を言っているかというと
嘘の罪にはなりません
しかし 人間それで止まるではなくて
堂々と嘘を言う 事実 自分の気持ちから言えば
自分が知ってます 違いますと
知ってるのに嘘を言う
そんなの大罪なんです
特にお釈迦様が証言を求めたところで
嘘をつくならば その人はワッサラですよと
ワッサラっていうのは
人間の社会で追い出しても不可触民族だよという
お釈迦様は不可触民族
インドにありましたから
それを認めなかった 人間そうならないんだと
平等やと それでお釈迦様はわざと定義を変えるんですよ
本当に不可触で接近してはいけない
ゴミ扱いするべき人間って誰ですかと言えば
証言を求めた時は 嘘を言う人やと
事実をねじ曲がる人やとかね
うん それからサッチャンハウェーサードゥタランラサーナ
この世の中で ラサっていうのは味
喜びを感じるもの いわゆる喜び感じるで苦しみがないでしょうに
では この世の中で究極的に喜びを感じるものって何なのかという
お釈迦様のサッチャン
真理ですよ それも覚えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
これ一つのあの お釈迦様の智慧の言葉で
サッチャンハウェーサードゥタランラサーナ
ラサっていうのは喜び感じるもの
味ということで 味の中でサッチャン
真理のみ あるいは真理だよ
確かに確実にという強調の言葉で
ハウェー セテンリという言葉で
確かに真理こそがラサーナ
喜び感じるものの中でサードゥタラン
とても優れているんだよと
だから事実をねじ曲がった我々の知識では
我々は喜び感じませんよ
我々は喜び感じているんだというふうに誤解しているだけで
人の話を聞いて いろんなものを食べてとかね
それは主観の世界ですからね
だから真理というのはお釈迦様がおっしゃっている真理なんですよ
それを知ると あの苦しみがすべて消えて
もう二度と生まれなくなっちゃうんです
お釈迦様はおっしゃるんですよ
この本当にこの概念を落とした時の得られる喜びっていうのは比べられないんだよと
ある日 堂々と言ったのは
お釈迦様に建物もない
住むところもなくて もう木の下であっちこっち座って何かご飯食べて
もう生活していて 服もないし
ない まあ衣も 3枚しかないし
で あの ある苦行する宗教家と対立になりまして
お釈迦様はその人 あんた方は苦労しているだけですよと
バカなことをやっているのではないかというふうな話を持っていったんですよ
言ったら その人々もちょっとこれ怒ったんですね
せっかく苦行しているのに
なんでケチつけるんですかと
言ったら あなたは楽をしているんではないかと
贅沢しているのではないかと
贅沢ってそんなにありがたいんだったら
ビンビサーラ国王様が
これもうものすごい大国なんですよ
そのビンビサーラ国王が一番贅沢しているで
あなたよりは 言ったら
お釈迦様はあんた方はね
ちゃんと調べないでいい加減なことを言っているのではないかと
では聞きますけど 言って質問して
質問して 答えもらって
それだったら結論は何ですかと
私がどれほど贅沢するかというと
値しないと 国王と お釈迦様が聞いたのは
その国王に たった 1日だけでも
何も考えないで 何もしないで
頭の中で何一つも概念なく
何一つも苦しみなく 徹底的な究極な安らぎを感じながら
一つも言葉を喋れない
一つもことをしない 体を動かす
動かすことさえも煩わしい
考えることも煩わしい
見たり聞いたりすることも煩わしい
それ全てストップして
究極的な安らぎ  1日ぐらいでも感じられますか？と
ただ 答えは1日のところか
お釈迦様は聞くのです
では 1 秒間でも 1 秒間でもできると
お釈迦様は私にとっては 1 週間もできますよと
だから誰が贅沢していますか？ということで
真理 お釈迦様がおっしゃっている真理なんです
それ知ってること自体がもう究極的な幸福
安らぎを感じられるものだから
すべての味わうものの中で真理こそが優れていると
それからなんで人間喧嘩するかというと
この自分思っている考え方が正しいと思っているだからなんですね
もともと正しくないんですよ
宗教的なことを言うと
人が死んじゃったら永遠になるという考え方ありました
それで人が死んじゃったらそれっきりで終わりますよという考え方もありました
全く対立している考え方でしょ
どちらでも宗教家で私が言っていることは正しいんだと
他の考え方は間違っているんだと当然言うんですよ
人が死んじゃったら永遠なりという人が
それなりのデータで主観で言ってるでしょうに
だから永遠ではない 全滅ですよと
断滅するんだよと 人が死んじゃったらという人とはすごい対立するんですよ
断滅するんだよと言った人もバカじゃないんだから
何か研究して考えて言ってることだから
しかし 人間考えることというのは自分の主観だから
好みで判断するわ 必ず合成するわ
子供のおもちゃ遊びで例えてください
決まってる そのままやってるわけじゃないんです
頭の中で合成する ですから
お釈迦様が言うのは そのようにお互いに何か考え方を持っていて
ある時はみんなそれを聞いて褒められる
ある時はその考え方をけなされると
それで自分こそ正しい
他人が間違っていると言って
必ず喧嘩 争いが成り立つと
それで真理知っている人は
何もそういう意見 概念は持たないと
えーと アッパンイエタンアランサマヤドゥエヴィワダッサパラーニブルミ
このいろんな概念については
そんなのはもう結構だよと
異論成り立つことはもう苦しみの原因やと私は喋り言いますよと
エータンビディスワナリワダエッタ
だから喧嘩しないで 争論しないで
平安というものを探し求めなさい
という風にもいろいろ考え方はたくさんあります
で 悟った人の心はどんな心かというと
例えがあります それもダンマパダに出てくるもので
鐘知ってますね お寺なんかにある
これが出来が良ければ良いほど
すごく音が立つんですよ
だからこの空気が風が吹いても音が出るとか
それで我々の心っていうのはそんなもので
何が触れてもすごい響いて音が作っちゃうんですね
概念作っちゃうんです
合成して心の中に ちょっと何かやっちゃうと
頭の中でボーンとものすごい妄想の概念いっぱい出てくる
瞑想すると知ってるでしょうね
ちょっと外の音が入っちゃって
いくらなんでもあれば車の音でしたと
私は音 音と言いなさいと言うでしょうに
そうすると 音とと言ったっても
それは車の音でしたと
それは救急車の音でしたと言うんですよ
そこでどういうことかというと
これ 一生懸命瞑想しているのに
ちょっと音が耳に入った瞬間で
いきなりボーンと巨大に概念が現れてきて
それからこの響くということを次から次へと考えて考えて妄想してしまって
音と言うと もう結構時間経っているんですよ
だからその働きある限りは
もうまあとっくに悟ってないんですよ
もう鐘と同じなんですよ
何を触れてもすぐ音を出してしまう
だから目から何か入っちゃうと
頭の中でいきなり強烈にもう妄想
概念のもう洪水みたいなもので
竜巻みたいなもので現れてくる
舌に何か触れただけで
体に何か触れただけでもう竜巻が立ち上がっちゃうんですね
頭の中で その状態でみんな苦しんでいる
それで悟ったということは
あの鐘にヒビが入っちゃうんですよ
そうするとどうなりますかね
叩いても叩いても音が出てこない
あの妄想 概念のあの洪水が出てこない
落ち着いている ですから
このダンマパダの百三十四番目の偈
サチェーネーリースヤッターナンカンソーウパハトヤタ
自分を自分の自己というか
自分の心を 鐘が割れたような状態にするならば
エーサパットーセニッバーナ
その人がもう涅槃を体現しているんだと
サーランボーテーネリッジョテ
彼が反対して対立して概念を作って
相手と喧嘩するということは成り立たないんだと
だからこの涅槃やら悟りやら言ったって
みんな何やこれ？とかね
本当にあるのかとかね
そんなのは昔話ではないかとかね
昔のブッダが悟ったかもしれない
仏教の人だったらね 昔のブッダとか
そういう人が悟ったかもしれない
今我々にできるくはないとかね
なんかすごい超越したもので
形而上学的なもので 具体的なものではないというふうに思ってますが
この例えでわかるでしょうし
涅槃って ああ もうもう心が落ち着いたと
普段普通我々はちょっと音入ったら
ものすごい強烈に妄想
概念の流れが現れてきて
耳に何か入って 目に何か入った瞬間で
ものすごい もう時々もうもうどれほど逆なぶるかというと
もう子供頃まで行ったりもする
ちょっとしたこと あの強烈な働きが完全に停止する
それ一回作ってみれば
これで事実知ったことになります
一回作ってみれば だから別にもう誰かから免許証をもらう必要ない
あんた悟っているんだよとかね
自分で知ってます 心はもう心という鐘がもうもうひび割れが入っているんだと
だから人を何言おうが
何見せようが うちは平安だと
それは壊れませんと ものすごい具体的に知ることはできます
そこで悟った人は それからまあ世間に合わせていうことは言いますが
考えたりもしますよ でも論理的にしか考えません
あることもないことも
妄想することはない 考えることはあります
人と喋ったり 人があまりにも汚れて
もうものすごいもうみっともない服装で
あんたもうちょいしっかりしなさいよとかね
そういうふうなことを言ったり
俗世間に合わせて言葉を使ったりするんだけど
強烈な内の流れがない
で それがもう真理の世界で
そういうことで話を終了しましょう
だから本当のことを知りたいと言ってますが
本当は本当のことを知りたくない状態
本当のことを言うと 我々はとことん逃げ回る
それから 知りたい知りたいと思うことは
我々の心の中で不満があるんだから
苦しんでいるんだから
物足りなくなっちゃって
ずっといろんなことを探し求めて
キリがない 苦しみは続く
それでさらに煩悩が生まれている
高慢やら人を馬鹿にすることやら
私は知ってるんだよと
あんた方は知らんではないかとかね
そうなったりする 逆に何か知識を得たならば
それをもう武器にして人を搾取したり
人をいじめたり 殺したりまでする
核兵器なんか作ることにはすごい敏感で反対する国々が
もうしょっちゅう研究して核兵器開発している
だから人も作っちゃうと自分には怠けませんだから他は誰も作ってはいけません
私だけ作りますよと という態度まで取る
だからそれは自分を得た知識で相手を脅そうと苦しめようと殺そうということでしょうね
ですから 知識を得たら
人間というのは余計なない煩悩まで生まれてくる
それはキリがない その点で我々は境界線を引いて
私の役に立つ 日常生活に役に立つぐらいの情報を得て
それで落ち着きますと
残りの能力で真理を知ります
知るために使いますよと
ということをします それからどんな概念があっても
あの人うるさいとかね
この人可愛いとか 東京は住みたくないとかね
そういういろいろ概念
人間にはあります もう悟った人にもあるんでしょう
あってもそんなのは一時的な現象であると
例えば東京には住みたくないという人は
ある条件の中で言うんですよ
聞いてみれば なんで住みたくないんですかと
こういうわけ そのわけなかったら住むでしょうに
だから東京には住みたくないということは
絶対的な真理ではありません
もし人が地球の中で この
あれ なんて言いますか
経緯と言うんですか？ アティチュード
ロンジチュードありますね
この時点にはいたくないというならば
しょうがないんです もう誰もそれは言わないでしょうに
そういうことだから 条件
で 一時的であると だからあまり執着しない
しがみつかない どんな意見にも
そういう風に訓練してみれば
大変楽な生き方が現れてくると思います
どうもありがとうございます